hey David can you talk about Florida and
weather Florida could decide whether
Trump stays or goes in 2020 there's some
interesting stuff going on in Florida
which we just haven't really had time to
talk about in the last week or so last
couple weeks with the Kohen testimony
and you know I don't have to give you
the full list of it there's a general
idea that Georgia and Texas could become
swing states and that Florida which has
been a swing state could become a more
solidly blue state there are demographic
arguments that can be made about Florida
there are political arguments that could
be made which I guess are still kind of
led by demographics I guess the the case
is mostly demographic around Florida
possibly becoming more reliably blue
rather than a swing state and case in
point there's a new poll from Ben Dixon
and dimande International which shows
that 40% of registered Florida voters
say they think Donald Trump should be
reelected 53 percent of registered
Florida voters do not support a second
term for Donald Trump now normal caveats
normal margin of error with that poll
but that's usually two to four percent
that's not a big deal registered versus
likely voters actually is a bigger deal
not to mention that it's still sort of
early we don't know who the alternative
can that it would be for Floridians
because we just don't know what's going
on with the Democratic primary but these
are early numbers that are starting to
suggest a problem for Trump so the
zoomed-out question is about whether
Florida could become a more reliably
blue state in the future as we go
forward and the answer is yes it could
but it's a little early to make that
assessment the more immediate question
is can Trump get reelected if he doesn't
win Florida and you know it's the the
difficulty about asking that question
about any particular state like we could
say well does this Trump need Wisconsin
again or whatever mathematically he may
not but there
a sort of more holistic analysis that
has to be done which is if Trump loses a
state he won in 2016
isn't it likely that there's probably a
broader kind of shift of the tide turn
of the tide against him and he would
lose a number of states so I think it's
always difficult to separate out
separate out any one state except that
because Florida is often or almost
always so close and can go either way
Florida may genuinely be responsible for
either putting Trump back in the oval
office for another four years or pulling
him out of the Oval Office now we can't
ignore when we talk about Florida and
how close it's likely to be and how
there are always irregularities because
of this kind of patchwork of different
mini elections that are taking place in
Florida on a locality to locality basis
locality by locality basis maybe better
said I have been increasingly convinced
over the last six to eight weeks that
Donald Trump is laying the groundwork
for contesting the results of the 2020
election if they don't go his way in
Florida if if we have 2016 repeated with
Florida flipping and it's close I think
it's almost guaranteed that foul play is
going to be called by Donald Trump and
then it could once again come down to a
judicial situation which in 2000 led to
george w bush becoming president of the
united states instead of Al Gore I'm
very interested in what may be happening
in the future in Florida but the more
immediate question is what is going to
happen with Donald Trump in Florida and
is he going to accept it and the case
that he is building for not accepting
the results includes that both Trump and
other flunkies like Sarah Huckabee
Sanders have been starting to respond
any time there's a new criticism of
Trump over the last six to eight weeks
from Democrats Sarah Huckabee Sanders
and others around Trump I'm paraphrasing
here are sort of saying they're
realizing that they can't win on the
truth so they're starting to attack the
president with lies and that is a way
that I could
imagine Trump starting to lay the
groundwork for they couldn't have
defeated me fairly so we have to look at
foul play and question the results or
whatever else kind of a separate
question from that of the political
implications of Florida but Florida is
going to be interesting in the immediate
Texas and Georgia are going to be
interesting in the next couple of
elections 2024 and 2028